Vladimir Putin es el único político no
italiano capaz de explicar en una
entrevista
las ventajas de tener sexo en grupo "algunos piensan que el
sexo en grupo es mejor que el normal
porque al ser un trabajo colectivo es
más fácil escaquearse pero ya te digo que es cuestión de cada uno"
supongo a que esto es lo que aprendes
cuando haces estas visitas oficiales a
Silvio Berlusconi, pero hablando de
Rusia y de penetraciones, tenemos dos
noticias que en su día pasaron
desapercibidas por los medios pero que
son muy importantes: la primera es que
el año pasado Gazprom anunció que
duplicaría las perforaciones de
petróleo en el artículo "Gazprom
duplicó su producción de petróleo en
Prirazlomnaya el año pasado. La
plataforma en el mar de Pechora produjo
más de ochocientas mil toneladas de
petróleo en 2015" y la segunda es que la
semana pasada rusia anunció nuevas
operaciones militares en el ártico
"protegiendo infraestructuras clave para
el ejército ruso del ataque de los
comandos especiales de la OTAN" muchos
pensaréis que el polo norte no es más
que la casa de papá noel pero es mucho
más importante que todo eso para
empezar es una de las mayores
yacimientos de petróleo del mundo y
está prácticamente inexplorado
pero por encima de todo eso el ártico
puede ser una de las mayores rutas
comerciales a nivel internacional
simplemente mirad este mapa: imaginad que somos un barco que sale de Inglaterra y
tiene que ir hasta Japón.
Hasta ahora, esta es la ruta que
tendríamos que seguir sin embargo si
pudiéramos ir por el Ártico,
podríamos ahorrarnos hasta la mitad del
tiempo.
Hasta hace 50 años era casi impensable
surcar el Ártico pero ahora la
tecnología para construir barcos
rompehielos es cada vez más barata, de
hecho casi todos se hacen en Finlandia.
Aquí podemos ver algunos ejemplos de
barcos.
Sin embargo el Polo Norte tiene un problema y es que nadie sabe a qué estado pertenece.
Durante años como a casi nadie le
importaba lo que ocurría por esta zona
lo que hicieron fue dividir el casquete
polar en gajos de tal forma que cada gajo
correspondería a una de los países
colindantes: uno para Rusia, otro para
Estados Unidos, Canadá, Noruega Dinamarca y Finlandia.
Sin embargo en cuanto descubrieron que
el polo norte es una mina de oro dijeron
"cuidado, cuidado" que esas fronteras ya no nos interesan y ahí es cuando empezó
esta batalla legal por ver qué parte
corresponde a cada estado.
Si nos vamos al derecho internacional
cada nación tiene derecho a 200
kilómetros de costa que serían sus
aguas territoriales.
Sin embargo en este caso hay bastantes
disputas porque por ejemplo Noruega
tiene esta isla que veis aquí así que
la teoría a la que se agarran sobre
todo Rusia y Noruega es la de la
plataforma continental es decir el
territorio nacional llegaría hasta
dónde llega la plataforma continental
de cada país, pero claro como en el
ártico hace mucho frío y el mar está
congelado durante la mitad del año es
muy difícil comprobar hasta dónde
llega tu plataforma continental. Se han llegado a hacer auténticas locuras para afianzar
la soberanía sobre el territorio.
Por ejemplo el año pasado Rusia lanzó
boyas al fondo del mar con una banderita
rusa para así poder decir que esa parte
de plataforma continental era suya.
En el caso de Noruega literalmente subvencionan con 30.000 euros al año a todos los habitantes de
esta isla, que es la isla de Svalbard,
solamente para poder decir que tienen
población noruega en esa zona y poder
reclamar que es suyo pero la cosa no se
queda aquí porque también hay un
problema ecológico, según dice Greenpeace
explotar el petróleo del ártico
causaría un daño tremendo al medio
ambiente.
De hecho, distintos grupos ecologistas
han estado presionando tanto al gobierno
canadiense y al gobierno americano para
que no autoricen a Shell, la empresa Shell,
para que pueda hacer perforaciones en
esa zona cuando intentaron hacer lo
mismo en Rusia les metieron en la
cárcel algo que en un principio nos
podría sonar habitual dado el modo de
gobierno de nuestro querido amigo Putin.
Sin embargo en este caso hubo algo
llamativo y es que a las dos semanas de
encarcelar a dos activistas de
greenpeace le soltaran "la comisión de
investigación rusa quería acusarlos
de piratería delito castigado con penas
de hasta 15 años de cárcel pero el
presidente ruso no está por la labor".
no sólo eso además vladimir putin
salió a la prensa diciendo "Putin aprecia
las nobles motivaciones de
Greenpeace
aunque condena sus métodos". Cuando
Putin dice que tus intereses son nobles
es para echarse a temblar. Y aquí es donde empieza la teoría de la conspiración
porque mucho dicen que Putín podría
estar subvencionando en secreto a grupos
ecologistas en Noruega Canadá y EEUU para así ser él el único que
pueda explotar el petróleo del Ártico.
Personalmente yo creo que es casi
imposible justificar este tipo de
alianzas en las sombras
lo que sí está claro es que por ahora
los grupos ecologistas que le vienen muy
bien a los intereses de Rusia y que al
gobierno de Putin necesita
desesperadamente buscar nuevos
yacimientos de petróleo porque su
economía se está estancando y depende
prácticamente en su totalidad del crudo.
Por eso el hecho de que rusia esté
haciendo operaciones militares en el
ártico y está gastando tantísimo
dinero en adaptar su ejército para las
condiciones extremas del polo norte
significa que tienen muchísimo interés
en mantener su soberanía sobre esa zona
y prepararse para cualquier potencial
conflicto con Noruega o con EEUU.
Repito que estamos hablando de una ruta
comercial importantísima y uno de los
mayores yacimientos de petróleo del
mundo.
Por su parte la Unión Europea también quiere su trozodel pastel y
ya ha propuesto a rusia algún tipo de
cooperación para explotar los recursos
del ártico ya nos he dicho que
Finlandia es el principal fabricante de
barcos rompehielos del mundo lo que
significa que muy probablemente rusia
necesitaría la tecnología europea para
poder explotar el petróleo del Polo
Norte.
Esto no hace sino meterle más hierro a la
cuestión
Y todo esto en una zona totalmente virgen totalmente desconocida por el ser humano y que poco
a poco estamos empezando a descubrir. Por eso es un tema que a mí personalmente
me fascina el resto os lo dejo a vuestra
propia interpretación en las próximas
semanas voy a volver a hablar sobre
putin porque hay muchísima tela que
cortar sobre este personaje.
Mientras tanto suscribiros al canal si no lo habéis hecho ya y nos vemos la próxima
semana
Un abrazo y hasta pronto!